Um, so, today we start a three-part
series on the French Revolution,
which I believe to be the most
significant event in human history.
Okay? So, let me very quickly explain
its significance.
So, um,
as I keep on mentioning in this class,
it is the religious religious worldview
that underpins society and civilization.
It is what allows society to function.
And, um, to oversimplify, there have
been four major
religious worldviews in human history.
Okay? So, let's go over them briefly.
The first is what we call the animistic.
And this is basically during the Ice
Age, when we were hunter-gatherers,
and we were just roaming the Earth.
Okay? And there are three major keywords
that underlie this worldview. Uh,
balance,
harmony,
and oneness.
We do not believe that we were different
from the plants, the animals,
uh, that lived on this planet. We were
one with them. We were interconnected
with them.
We didn't fear death because life and
death were part of the same continuous
cycle. Okay? So, this is the idea of the
animistic, um,
worldview.
From then, we moved on to the
polytheistic.
Polytheistic, many gods.
And the three main ideas that underpin
the polytheistic worldview are
action,
ritual,
and fate.
No one, not even the gods, can escape
their fate.
Our fate has been preordained.
What courage is is the willingness to
embrace
with with honor and with dignity your
fate. So, think of Hector as he is about
to battle Achilles. He knows he is going
to get killed
and he's afraid. He shakes, but he still
confronts his fate and he dies.
And that's what expected of you in the
Viking world, in the Greek world, in the
Roman world, to face your death with
honor and dignity. To live your life
with courage, action, but in a
ritualistic manner.
Okay? In a way that the community
expects of you. And to embrace your
fate, no matter what it is. Okay? That
is a polytheistic worldview.
Then Then this
uh leads us to the monotheistic
worldview.
Monotheistic, okay? So, the monotheistic
are the Jews, the Christians, and the
Muslims. The three major ideas that
underpin the monotheistic worldview are
faith,
orthodoxy,
and truth.
There is an eternal truth called God. We
must have faith in him.
And faith and truth are expressed
through orthodoxy. There is a set of
beliefs that you cannot question, that
you must believe.
And you must
live your life according to this
orthodoxy.
Okay? So, these are These are three
major ideas underlying monotheistic.
Now,
we move to the modern period. Okay?
Another word that we can use for modern
is uh
deism. Okay?
Deism.
You may have heard of this, but the idea
of deism is that there is a God. God
created the universe,
but then he left us.
He doesn't care about what happens
anymore because the world he created was
perfect and it is up to us to understand
the perfect laws of the universe and
then perfect our lives according to
these laws. Okay? So, let's say if
deism, this is important because deism
is the founding religion of both the
American
as well as the French Revolutions. All
right? And there are three major beliefs
that underpin deism.
The first is reason.
Okay? So, rather than faith, we have to
use our reason.
Because that's the gift that God gave us
before he left. We are able to using
logic, using intuition, using skepticism
to understand how the world works. Okay?
Reason.
All right? But, reason by itself is not
enough. You have to engage in debate
in order
to fully use our reason.
You may not able to reason out for
yourself the truth, but when but in the
debate,
you're able to hear out the truth. Okay?
And if we do this, if we continue to to
exercise our reason, if we continue to
engage in debate, what is often called
um the marketplace of ideas,
this will lead to the idea of progress.
Okay?
So, what's happened is that the modern
period is responding to the Christian
period
um
by replacing faith with reason,
orthodoxy with debate, and truth with
progress.
Okay? And these three ideas, reason,
debate, and progress,
are the foundations of the period we
live in today, called the modern period.
It is It is about these three ideas are
the foundations of our school system,
for our universities,
for our for our scientific um
institutions, okay? Does that make
sense?
All right.
Now, having gone through these four
different periods, I want to do some
analysis, okay?
The first analysis is to explain to you
how these changes manifest manifest
themselves.
So, the animistic period is the most
natural. It's what It's what makes the
most sense. Quite honestly, if animals
had a religion, it would probably be an
animistic religion, okay?
So, how do we transition from the
animistic to polytheistic? Well, the
main reason is because of civilization,
okay? Because of mass society,
civilization.
Because we chose to settle down and
learn agriculture and develop religious
systems.
All right? And with that comes war,
comes hierarchy, comes inequality.
And as such, we develop the polytheistic
worldview, all right?
From the polytheistic worldview, we then
transition into the monotheistic
worldview. Why? Because of Christianity.
All right? Christianity.
Remember, um
you're usually taught that Christianity
is oh, um Jesus dies and then everyone
becomes a Christian.
That's not what happened, okay? As you
learn in this class, Christianity was a
mechanism developed by the Roman Empire
in order to assimilate
the Jews.
And then later on to assimilate
um barbarians
who are
economic migrants into the Roman Empire.
Basically, it was a tool of control for
the Roman Empire, okay?
But then, you have this mass transition
from monotheism, the Christian period,
into modernism, all right? And this
turning point, which is the most radical
turning point in human history, is what
we call the French Revolution.
Without the French Revolution, modernity
could not
happen.
All right? And
um what's amazing about the French
Revolution is it is entirely
unprecedented. We've never had We've
never had anything like this before.
It was entirely unpredictable.
It was unique in human history.
All right? So, we will spend our next
three classes to understand how the
French Revolution happened. Because
without understanding the French
Revolution, you cannot understand future
events, especially communism, the rise
of communism, World War I, World War II.
None of these things would have been
possible without the French Revolution.
Okay?
All right. So, um another thing that's
really important for us to understand is
that all four worldviews still exist
today. All right? There are still people
who believe in animism, polytheism,
okay? But they're the minority. The
dominant people are still the
monotheists, okay? And they're in
competition with
the modernists, okay? Who um
who are who are the educated elite.
Okay? Um so, this conflict is still
going on today. The other thing that's
really important for us to understand is
none of these beliefs is inherently
superior to the other.
Okay? You can make the argument You
cannot make the argument to me, at
least, that one is better than the
other.
But,
new systems believe they are superior to
the other, okay? To the previous. So,
the polytheists believe they are
superior to the animists.
The monotheists think they are superior
to the polytheists. And the And the
deists think they are superior to the
monotheists.
Okay? And because of this sense of
superiority,
um
they
try to crush previous worldviews.
Okay? So, these four worldviews are not
in competition with each other,
but the new ones seek to displace the
old ones. And this what's And this has
led to a lot of conflict throughout, um,
human history.
All right? So, this is the overall
framework we're working with. I know
it's a bit simple,
but for the purpose of this class, it's
it's it's good enough, okay? All right.
So, now what I'm going to do is explain
the framework for the next three
classes.
Okay? My argument to you
is the French Revolution was ultimately
a religious crusade.
That is the main thesis
of this of the next three classes. In
each class, we'll introduce different
elements of this crusade that made it
possible.
For a crusade to happen, you need three
different types of geniuses.
You need the poet
to
envision the future, okay? The poet.
But then you need the prophet
who has the courage to take the people
into this new land.
And then you need the prince or the
conqueror
who has the conviction and the
determination to physically conquer this
new land and expand the revolution,
okay?
So, the poet
is Rousseau or Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
Um he wrote The Social Contract. We'll
be focusing on him mainly today.
Okay, he's the one who introduces the
idea that it's possible to build a new
world based entirely on reason itself.
All right?
That's Rousseau. Then you have the
prophet.
The prophet is the one who has the
courage to lead the people into the new
land even though it may cost him his
life. And this person, his name is
Maximilien Robespierre.
Okay?
Robespierre is, in my opinion,
one of the most
misunderstood
and underrated
individuals in human history.
Um
um next class we'll focus on
Robespierre.
Without Robespierre, the French
Revolution could not have succeeded.
And then now you need a prince
who will
take the ideas of the prophet and he
will militarily expand into the world
and conquer a new world and build a new
world. And this person's name, of
course, is
Napoleon Bonaparte.
Napoleon.
And this is the last class.
All right? And my argument to you today
is that without the active
cooperation of all three,
if they're not able to build on each
other's work, the French Revolution
would not have succeeded. Because if you
just look at the French Revolution, the
odds were so against the
revolutionaries, right? They were not
only against the aristocracy and their
own people,
they were up against the entire world.
Britain,
Prussia, Russia, Austria, everyone
wanted to destroy the revolution before
it threatened their um their nations.
So, the odds were completely against the
French Revolution, but they succeeded.
It was only because of the cooperation
of these three particular types of
geniuses who saw the poet, Robespierre
the prophet, and Napoleon the
prince.
Okay? So, that's what we'll what we'll
be doing these next three classes. All
right.
So, um
let's talk about
the ideas that underpin the French
Revolution, the Enlightenment. Okay? How
do we get into the modern period where
the ideas are now reason, debate, and
progress?
Okay.
So, let's go back to Dante.
Dante's Divine Comedy
is a prophecy.
It is a new
um understanding of the world. Okay? So,
what the what the Divine Comedy does is
what it helps people do is take all
these new structural forces that are
being unleashed onto the world and
understand it in a new way that
unleashes three major movements, okay?
These are of course the Renaissance,
the
uh Reformation,
and the and the scientific revolution,
okay?
Now, as these these things are
happening, what else is happening is the
gunpowder revolution.
The gunpowder
revolution.
And these things combine
in order to create massive structural
changes within European society. Okay?
So, we discussed this, but there are
three major changes that are happening
throughout this period. The first is the
transition from
feudal-
-ism
to a nation.
Okay? The idea of a nation. Okay? At
first, it's an absolute monarchy, but
then after the French Revolution, it
transitions into a nation-state. Okay?
From decentralization into into
centralization, basically. That's the
first major change. Second major change
is
from rural
to urban.
Basically,
from agriculture into industry.
Okay? And the third major change is from
religion
into science.
All right? And this is what what's
happening in Europe
um
because of the gunpowder revolution.
Now, what's important about this is with
these structural changes comes massive
demographic, political, and economic
changes. Essentially, what's what's
happening is that new groups of people
are being created.
And these groups of people are who we
call who we collectively call the middle
class.
Okay? So, let's look at the middle
class. All right. So,
previously in Europe,
there are
just roughly speaking, two major groups,
okay? There's the nobility and the
clergy, okay?
There's almost no difference between the
two because they intermarry, they come
from the same families. Okay? But
they're they're the leading elite
of society, okay? You have the top
people, the nobility and the clergy, and
then at the
other end are the peasants and slaves.
And but of course, I mean like this is
not that simple. I mean, you will you
always have I mean in a class you always
have um trades people, you always have
people working
um in towns. But they're minority.
And what happened what's happening now
because all all these changes in society
is they now become an increasingly
powerful
um
group of people. They're the ones who
are driving economic
change, okay? Now,
the middle class an extremely
complicated
set of people, but roughly speaking, we
can divide them into three major
categories, okay? Three major
categories.
The first is what we call the
bourgeoisie.
The bourgeoisie, okay? Um the
bourgeoisie is um a French term that we
use, and it comes actually from the
German, which is burger.
Burger means the leading citizens of a
town, the burgers.
And the leading citizens of a town
usually are the factory owners,
the merchants, the people who trade,
the bankers, the people who have control
of money, the lawyers.
Okay? So, these are the bourgeoisie.
These are the elite.
And this is a
um new group of people that work very
closely with the nobility,
but they have some differences, okay?
The thing to remember about these people
is they tend to be conservative. Because
in terms of status,
they already have
um all all the status that they want,
okay?
And over time what will happen is that
the king and nobility will increasingly
depend on the bourgeoisie for financing.
Okay? So, they pay for wars, they pay
for new new industry, they pay for
roads, okay? So, the bourgeoisie are the
ones who are most heavily taxed. But,
they're usually conservative. They're
really happy with the way things are. At
the other end,
um
sorry, next to the bourgeoisie are what
are called the petite
bourgeoisie.
All right?
And these people are not rich, but
um
they're solidly middle class. They're
comfortable where they are, okay? These
people are school teachers. Uh maybe
they're restaurant owners. Maybe they're
notaries, okay?
So, the thing about these people is that
they tend to be aspirational.
They're not happy with their life, they
want more. And as such, they are
opportunistic.
Okay? Usually, the people who are most
likely to lead the revolution come from
members of the petite bourgeoisie.
Okay? So, most of the uh leaders of the
French Revolution, the most radical
members, um were provincial lawyers.
Okay? Lawyers who worked in small
cities. They're not part of the elite,
the bourgeoisie,
okay? But, they're pretty comfortable
where they are. Okay? They're the
provincial elite.
If you look at the communist revolution,
right? Mao Zedong, he was a petite
bourgeoisie, right? He was a provincial
elite, not a
Beijing elite. All right? And the last
group is what will what will be referred
to in the future, okay? Not now, as the
proletariat.
Proletariat.
The proletariat are basically
artisans,
craftspeople,
people who work in cities and in the
urban centers, and they have a
specialized craft that makes them
valuable, okay? They're not peasants,
they're not poor, but the problem is
they are very precarious.
Okay? Precarious.
What this means is that as the
scientific revolution um
pro- progresses, new technology will
start to replace the artisans.
Okay?
Um like a sewing machine.
And as such, they lose their
livelihoods. So, their job their lives
are very precarious. Therefore, they're
most likely they most likely tend
towards violence.
So, these are the foot soldiers
of revolutions. Okay? The petite
bourgeoisie are often the thought
leaders,
um
but the proletariat are the ones who
provide
the muscle.
Okay? So, if you look at most
revolutions, this is how it works.
What's really important for us to
understand is that first of all, these
categories are not strict.
Okay? There are lots of
interchange between the proletariat and
the and the peasantry. There's a lot
lots of interchange between the
bourgeoisie and the nobility, okay?
These categories are not
static. The other thing is that
the loyalties of each group will change
according to the circumstance.
Okay? So, the petit bour- petit
bourgeoisie is not definite that they
will
rebel against the bourgeoisie. It
depends on their economic interest.
And it is not definite
that
the peasants will work with the petit
petit bourgeoisie against the nobility.
In fact, during the French Revolution,
this is really important, the nobility
and the peasants working together to
suppress revolution. Why? Because the
French Revolution wanted to destroy the
Catholic religion.
The peasants love their religion, okay?
The peasants
want wanted to be Catholic and they want
to protect their priests.
So, there was a massive civil war going
on in France between the peasants and
the proletariat. And that that we kind
of intuitively think is like, why would
poor people be fighting against poor
people? Well, it's because they have
different religious interests. Okay?
Does that make sense? All right. So,
this is a framework that I want you guys
to remember. There are different groups.
This is an oversimplification.
Um
and their loyalties will change. So,
during the revolution
the the loyalties will change
and it will mark different stages in the
French Revolution.
And you can use this framework to also
understand future revolutions,
especially the Communist Revolution.
Okay?
Um and it's also important for us to
remember that most revolutions will
fail, okay?
All right.
So,
um
this is this is the middle class. Now,
thing thing about the middle class, the
thing with with the thing about uh new
groups is that
what they have to do
is they have to establish
group solidarity.
Okay? And the the way you do that is by
establishing group identity.
So, how is it that the middle class is
different from everyone else?
Okay? And as we discussed, what the
middle class will do
is they will slowly adopt
the Enlightenment principles of reason,
debate,
and progress.
Okay? That's how they how That's how the
middle class or most members of the
aspirational middle class will try to
differentiate themselves from everyone
else.
By embracing the Enlightenment. And
that's why we have enlightenment.
Okay? So, uh
over time, these things these things
will become much more concrete, okay?
So, what makes the middle class
identity?
The first is the idea of education.
Second is the idea
of achievement.
And the third is the idea of morality.
All right? So, what is the middle class?
The middle class are those who embrace
these three ideas: education,
achievement, and morality, right?
If you're in the middle class, you'll be
much more educated than the nobility and
the peasantry. You will read books. You
will read newspapers. That's why we have
newspapers, okay? Because the middle
class wants information.
Uh achievement, the achievement ethos is
I will always strive to be better. I
will I will my children to be better
than me, okay? If you're peasant, you
don't believe your children will live
will live a better life. If you're
nobility, you don't really care if your
children will live a better life. But
for the middle class, it's very
important that their children live
better lives, okay? So, the idea of the
achievement ethos, to work hard. Okay?
So, you guys should understand this
because you're all members of the middle
class in China, right? And the last is
the idea of morality, and this is really
important. Um
morality is
uh especially when it comes to sexual
morality, all right? Sexual morality.
So, the idea is that
um
if you're a poor person, the thing about
being poor is you have no control over
your body.
So, during this time
of industrialization, what's happening
is a lot of peasants are moving into the
cities.
And what are women doing? Well, they're
becoming prostitutes.
There are
tons and tons of prostitutes
in these cities at this time in Europe,
okay? You We just walk We just walk on
the street and guess what? There are
prostitutes everywhere.
So, as a poor person, you have actually
no control over your body. So, with the
middle class, the way that they
differentiate themselves is by saying
that we have enough resources to protect
our bodies.
And if you're part of the middle class,
then you're expected to adhere to a very
strict
um morality, okay? Does that make sense?
That's That's where we get the idea of
morality from, from the development of
the middle class.
As a middle class, you have sexual
um
you are much more sexually pure, but
also you have a new idea called
childhood.
If you are a poor person, your child age
six starts to work, okay? At age 10,
he or she may be working in a factory
and by 12 may be dead.
What the middle class can do is give
his or her child
a childhood, okay?
Um the modern concept of childhood comes
from this period. And And we'll be
looking at this.
Right?
Okay. So,
that's the idea here.
The Enlightenment basically was a
movement
in which a new group of people, the
middle class, they've always existed,
but now they in they exist in quantity.
And they have more resources than they
used to have before, especially
literacy, access to information.
They have more wealth.
They have more technology. They are the
future leaders of the world.
And as such, they want to embrace a new
identity.
And that's why we have Enlightenment,
okay? Enlightenment was basically a
period when they tried to bring the
ideas of science into society in order
to create a
new middle class identity and it still
exists today.
All right. So, that is the basic
framework for today. Now, we will look
at specific
writers and thinkers of the
Enlightenment.
Okay, any questions so far?
Okay, great.
All right.
So, let's start looking at some major
thinkers of Enlightenment.
Okay.
All right. So, um today's class is on
the European Enlightenment. Now, what's
really important for us to remember is
that there are major ideological
differences between the British
Enlightenment and the European
Enlightenment. Okay, European just means
um
France, Germany, Netherlands, that that
Okay, basically continent of continental
Europe. The The ideas that develop in
Europe will be different from the ideas
that develop in Britain. After the
French Revolution, we'll look at Britain
specifically, but now I just want to
focus on the European Enlightenment,
okay? So, please remember that. The
British Enlightenment and the European
Enlightenment have contrasting ideas,
even though most historians consider
them part of the same historical
movement.
All right. So, what is Enlightenment? It
is a movement to systematize and
institutionalize Dante to create a new
European middle class identity. So, all
these ideas are coming from Dante, but
there is a major difference that we must
remember.
Remember, the Enlightenment for the
Enlightenment thinkers,
what God left us
is the capacity to reason.
Through reason, we can access the mind
of God, okay? Reason is the fundamental
principle of the Enlightenment.
That's not Dante said, though, okay?
Dante said, "Love
is what God gave us. Love is the light
in us."
Now, you think, "Well, what's really
What's the difference between love and
reason?"
Okay, what I will do over the course of
the semester is show you is show you
that there's actually a huge, huge
difference between love and reason.
Specifically, reason is independent. You
can, by yourself, reason out things.
But love requires you to connect with
someone else, either your child, your
wife,
your mother, who who knows, okay? But
you must connect with someone else.
And because of because of that idea,
interconnectedness, it puts a
a restraint
on your reason.
But if you're capable of reasoning by
yourself, you can reason anything,
including concentration camps, nuclear
bombs,
uh
genocide, okay? So, there's a huge
difference between love and reason. Um
and it's really
important that the Enlightenment
thinkers
see reason as a central
organizing principle of human society
and not love, okay?
So, I I I just want you guys keep keep
that in mind as we move on. The
Enlightenment um happened mainly in
salons. These are places organized by
wealthy
bourgeoisie women, and these salons were
not political. They were mainly designed
to learn manners, speech, refinement,
right? Because they're trying to
differentiate themselves from the
nobility, the clergy, and the peasantry.
And one one way that that they want to
do this is through their
um education, through their knowledge,
expertise, okay? Salons.
Um in Britain,
they mainly spread ideas through coffee
houses.
All right?
Coffee houses. So, the idea of meeting a
coffee house comes from this period in
Britain.
Um
So, these women,
uh like Madame Laborde, were the ones
who were driving enlightenment
um
ideas.
Okay?
And these salons were places for the
leading intellectuals of the time to
come and debate
um ideas.
All right? So, these were the leading
women of that time. All right.
So, um there were there are lots and
lots of enlightenment thinkers.
Because this is this is a time of
literacy, right? People want to read.
There's a marketplace of ideas.
So, money can be made from writing
books. And that's why you have this
explosion of ideas, the marketplace of
ideas, during this time. But now I want
to just go through some of the major
thinkers
of the enlightenment, okay? The first
major thinker of the of the
enlightenment is René Descartes.
And René Descartes
wanted
He is a mathematician, he's a
philosopher.
Um he wanted to ask two questions. The
first question is, how do we know that
God exists?
And how do we know the soul exists?
Okay, these are the two questions that
he is trying to grapple with in his
philosophy. And he wrote a book called
Meditations on First Philosophy. This is
a really important book in development
of Western civilization, okay? We will
be referring to this book
um
quite often for the rest of the
semester. So, I want you guys to
remember this book, Meditations on First
Philosophy.
And so,
he's asking these questions. And let's
look at let's read a few
paragraphs from his book to understand
his thinking, okay?
It is some years now since I realized
how many false opinions I had accepted
as true from childhood onward and that
whatever I had since built on such shaky
foundations could only be highly
doubtful. All right. So,
what he's doing here is is saying,
"Okay, I want to know if God exists.
But first I must ask myself, what do I
believe
and how do I know if it's true or not? I
must look inside myself."
All right?
Hence I saw that at some stage my life
the whole structure would have to be
utterly demolished and that I would have
to begin again from the bottom up if I
wish to construct something lasting and
unshakeable in the sciences.
And what he's saying here is that
after I examine my own beliefs, I
recognize that
most of my beliefs are not true.
Okay? This is a radical departure from
previous traditions where
you know something is true because
someone really smart said it.
You refer to you you you defer to
authority, right?
That's the practice we have we use in
China where well, Confucius said this,
so this must be true.
And what what Descartes is saying is
that no, that's not true.
Okay? I myself have the capacity to know
if something is true and I have a
responsibility to reflect and question
everything I know.
And through that process of self-doubt,
self-examination, I can construct
something that is more truthful.
Okay? And this is the idea of
enlightenment.
All right? And this is the idea of
education, you know, when when we try to
to teach you critical thinking skills,
this is what we're trying to do, okay?
Trying to get you to question things so
that you may construct a more eternal
truth.
All right.
But this seemed to be a massive task and
so I postponed it until I had reached
the age when one is as fit as one would
ever be to master the various
disciplines.
So, to get to this point you also have
to go through a long process of
education, okay? You just can't be like,
"Okay, I'm going to do this right now."
You have to first learn these beliefs.
And then you have to go back and then
re-examine these beliefs.
I've delayed
so long that now I should be at fault if
I use up in deliberating
the time that is left for acting. The
moment has come, and so today I have
discharged my mind from all its cares
and have carved out a space of
untroubled leisure. I've withdrawn into
seclusion and shall at last be able to
devote myself seriously without
encumbrance to the task of destroying
all my former opinions.
Okay.
What he's doing here is saying that for
me to discover the truth, I just have to
rely solely on my reason.
Not debate,
not talking to others,
not reading old books, but by
self-examination.
Okay? And so, uh this is the beginning
of the book. We will read other sections
later on in in the semester, but this
this is the introduction, okay? So, this
project is a process of constant
self-examination.
And through this self-examination, what
he discovers is
everything is false.
How do we know the sky is blue? How do
we know the sky exists? We don't.
How do I know that the words I'm
speaking make any sense? I don't.
It's a constant process of
self-negation, okay?
But, what then he recognizes is what
what then he recognizes is that the only
way that I can actually engage in this
process of self-examination is through
doubt.
Right? So, what do I know to be true?
Doubt is true.
I doubt, therefore I am, right? You may
You know the expression, "I think,
therefore I am," right? It's actually uh
I doubt, therefore I am.
The Latin is, "Cogito, ergo sum.
Okay?
The thing that I know to be absolutely
true
is my capacity to doubt.
And that is who I am.
Therefore,
I exist.
And so, the capacity to doubt is my
soul, all right?
Now, how do I know that God exists?
Well, if God didn't exist,
then I would have I would not have the
capacity to doubt, right? Someone must
have given me the capacity to doubt, and
that must be God, whoever God is.
But now, how do I know that
God is good?
Right? Because God could be a trickster.
God could be the devil, and God could be
deceiving me.
And my capacity to doubt will only lead
me into error.
Okay? So, that's that's that's that's
the question he asked now. And then he
And then he says, "Well,
because God is perfect.
If you are perfect, you're incapable of
fault.
Therefore,
I know God is good.
Okay? And And obviously, this makes no
logical sense. This This is not logical.
It's It's what we call a tautology,
right? God is perfect, therefore I know
God is good. God is good, therefore he's
perfect. Okay? It makes no sense.
But
um what's important is that René
Descartes is asking us to challenge our
assumptions about the world. To doubt,
to reason. He's saying that the idea of
reason
is the most powerful force in the world.
More powerful than the church, more
powerful than dogma, more powerful than
the society itself, okay? Our individual
capacity to reason is what matters. It
is what allows us to have access to God.
Does that make sense? Right? So, this is
one of the major ideas underpinning
the Enlightenment.
All right. Now, let's move on to Goethe.
Johann Wo- Wolfgang von Goethe.
He is considered the greatest German
writer of all time.
And he wrote a book called Faust.
Okay?
Faust.
And we we will just read a few passages
from Faust. But Faust is also a very
quintessential Enlightenment
work of art, okay?
And so
the
book of Faust, it's based on another
book called the Book of Job, which we
find in the Bible. In the Book of Job
it's about this very pious individual
who is very faithful to God.
Okay, he's very wealthy, he has a lot of
children, he's very happy. He's very
devout. He he prays to God all the time,
he makes sacrifices to God all the time,
he gives he's very he's very generous,
he has a lot of friends.
One day God is in heaven and he's in a
meeting with Satan, okay? Satan in the
Bible means adversary. So Satan is
actually an archangel, an agent an agent
of of of God who roams the planet.
And
God is very proud of Job and he and he
says to Satan
"Have you seen Job? Do you see how
faithful he is to to me?" He's very
proud.
And Satan says
"God, he's only faithful to you because
he's rich, okay?
You take away his money, you take away
his children and he will curse you." And
God says "Fine, I make you this bet.
You can do anything you you can do
anything you want to him, but you must
not kill him. Okay, that's the only
condition."
So Satan
basically makes Job's life a living
hell.
All his children die in accidents, he
loses all his money, he becomes infected
with diseases, he's old, he's and and
eventually he curses God.
And he's like, "Why is God doing this to
me?" And then God appears before him and
says, "How dare you question me, God?
I create the world. What have you done
in your life, okay?" But basically God
goes on for a long, long time and curses
Job and says, "You as a human being have
absolutely no right to ever doubt, to
ever question me. I can do what I want.
I'm God. I'm a mystery.
Do not ever
think you can understand me. Do not ever
believe you can question me, okay? And
then what God does is he restores Job's
health and wealth, okay? So, it's a very
strange story.
And it's one that is that is meant to
inspire fear
among people.
And so, what Goethe does, that's really
interesting, is that he reimagines the
story of Job and turns it into a much
more confident, optimistic story that
captures the spirit of the
Enlightenment. Okay? Does that make
sense? The story goes like this.
Faust, he is a professor. He loves
learning. He's very curious.
But, what he recognizes is that
despite all his book learning, he
doesn't really have access to the truth.
He's not really learning new
information, new knowledge. He doesn't
feel as though he's accessing God. So,
he tries magic.
Um
one day, the Satan, and and Satan's name
here in Faust is name Mephistopheles,
okay? Mephistopheles
talks to God
and and Mephistopheles says to God,
"You know what? The worst thing you ever
did was allow humans the capacity to
reason. Because you're idiots, you're
stupid. If you're stupid and you can
reason, all it does is confuse you and
make you unhappy."
And then God is like, "Well, have you
met
Faust?
Faust is my favorite person in the whole
world because he's curious, he loves
learning. Eventually, through the
process of self-exploration, he will
discover the truth. He will get there. I
I have faith in Faust."
And Mephist- Mephistopheles says, "Fine,
I'll make you a bet. I bet you I I I can
make him complacent.
I bet you that I can make him not want
to learn anymore, to lose his curiosity.
And if I win this bet, then Faust will
become my servant, okay? His soul will
be will be mine. I will damn him to hell
for eternity, okay? And that's the bet."
All right. So, let's look at some
passages. This is Mephistopheles saying
to God, "Their lives will be a little
easier if you not let them glimpse the
light of heaven. They call it reason and
employ it only to be more beastly than
any beast." Okay. What's important first
to remember is that here Goethe is
invoking Dante, right? Remember, Dante
in Divine Comedy says that
love is the light of heaven.
And here, Goethe and
and the Enlightenment thinkers are
saying that no, it's reason that is the
light of heaven. In fact, in many ways,
Faust is a rewriting of the Divine
Comedy.
All right? So, Mephistopheles is saying
to God, "Reason is bad because it makes
people who are stupid more confused."
And then
God says, "Do you know Faust?" And
Mephistopheles says, "The doctor?" The
Lord says, "And my servant, okay? My
favorite person in the whole world."
Mephistopheles: "Indeed, he serves you
in a curious way. The fool is not
content with earthly food or drink. Some
ferment makes him want what is exotic,
yet he's half conscious of his father,
okay?
Faust wants to understand the world.
He's curious.
He's driven by his curiosity and his
imagination.
And Mephistopheles makes fun of him
because he'll never get there. Okay?
From heaven he claims as his the
brightest stars and from the earth all
of its highest joys, but nothing near
and nothing far away can satisfy a heart
so deeply agitated, okay? He's just too
curious. He can't be satisfied.
And the God says, "Though you Though now
he only serves me blindly ineptly,
I shall soon lead him into clarity. The
gardener knows when the sapling turns
green, the blossoms and fruit will
brighten future years." Okay? So, God is
saying
if he continues to be curious,
eventually I God will lead him into the
light. Okay? So, what's important for us
as humans is to
be curious and that's how we show our
faith in God.
Right?
Now,
so Mephistopheles and Faust
meet and Mephistopheles says to Faust,
"Listen, I know you want to know the
truth of of the world. I want I know you
want to experience the whole world whole
whole world, but you can't do it by
yourself. So, I will help you, okay? I
will grant you the knowledge of the
world, but
if at any point you become complacent,
you stop striving,
you're happy with the way things are,
you're happy with the moment, then you
will become my servant. Is that a deal,
Faust?" And Faust says, "Sure." Because
Faust does not believe that he can ever
lose his curiosity.
Okay?
So, what happens is all these strange
events where Faust falls in love with a
maiden named Gretchen.
And Gretchen falls in love with him.
And
they try to have sex, but the mother
gets in the way. So, Faust has Gretchen
kill the mother. The brother finds out
and tries to kill Faust. Faust kills the
uh brother. Gretchen get gets pregnant
and then has to kill the baby because
Faust has disappeared. And then Gretchen
basically dies in prison, okay? So, it
sounds terrible.
But what happens is that eventually
Gretchen forgives Faust because Gretchen
goes to heaven.
And Gretchen and then Faust has more
adventures. He becomes
um a servant to the king. He builds um
um a lot of roads and lots of cities. He
marries Helen of Troy. He goes back in
the past. Anyway, a lot of strange
things happen, okay? But what's
happening is that he's experiencing life
for all its for all its potential, for
its all its possibilities. And And so,
as he gets older, he's about to die. And
Mephistopheles comes to collect his
soul, okay?
And this is the
last speech of Faust before he dies.
A swamp lies there below the hill,
infecting everything I've done. My last
and greatest act of will succeeds when
that foul pool is gone. Okay, so he is
an architect and he is an urban planner
working for the government. He's a civil
servant, basically. And his job is to
make the city much more livable for
people, okay? To help to help civilize
the world. And he's taking pride in his
work.
Six six succeeds when that foul pool is
gone, okay? Let me make room for many a
million. Okay, let me let me
make space for more people.
Not wholly secure, but free to work on.
Green fertile fields where men and herds
may gain swift comfort from the new made
earth, quickly settled in those hills
embrace, piled high by a brave
industrial race. And in the center here,
a paradise whose boundaries hold back
the raging tide. And though it gnaws to
enter in by force, the common urge
unites to hold its course, okay? So,
he's taking pride in all that he's
accomplished and that he will
accomplish.
Okay? He's taking pride in this moment
when he's actively contributing to the
betterment of civilization.
But, because he's taking pride in this
moment,
he's now lost the bet to Mephistopheles,
right? He's now become complacent. He
wants to live in the moment. You can't
do that.
Yes, I surrender to this thought's
insistence. The last word wisdom ever
has to say, he only earns his freedom in
existence who's forced to win them
freshly every day.
Childhood, manhood, age, vigorous years
surrounded by dangers they'll spend
here. I wish to gaze again on such a
land, free earth where a free race and
freedom stand. Okay? So,
to be alive means to constantly struggle
to progress things. Okay?
And this is it. Then to the moment I
dare say, stay a while, you are so
lovely. He wants to stay in this moment
forever.
For eons then, never to fade away, this
pact of mine for all that's earthly,
anticipating here its deep enjoyment,
now I savor it that that highest moment.
Okay?
In this moment,
when he feel he's contributed to
development of society, he feels at
peace.
He feels
fulfilled.
Okay?
And so,
the irony is that
at this moment, when he's most
fulfilled,
he should be now he should now be damned
to hell, right?
But,
what happens
as Mephistopheles is about to claim
Faust's soul is
angels appear
and steal it from from Mephistopheles
Mephistopheles. Okay? The angels, pure
incandescence, whom its flames blast,
blissful of goodness is their existence.
Gathered together, rise now in praise.
Spirit can breathe here in pure waves.
So, God has come to save Faust.
They rise carrying away the immortal
part of Faust. Faust's soul is now in
heaven.
Mephistopheles says, "How then? Where
did they vanish to? You took me by
surprise, you adolescents. Now with what
they've salvaged from the tomb, as their
own prize, they've flown off to heaven.
They've stolen a great and unique
treasure, that noble soul mortgaged to
my pleasure. They've snatched it away
with cunning even. But whom could I even
complain to anyway?" Okay?
So, Mephistopheles knows he's been
tricked,
but he has no say in the matter.
Okay?
And so,
Faust, it is considered the greatest
work of German literature.
And the main message is
God loves us.
God wants us to be curious. God wants us
to to explore, to challenge ourselves,
to grow. And we do that, God will always
protect us, no matter how many stupid
things we do.
Okay? God is ultimately about
forgiveness,
and love, and mercy, and kindness, and
generosity.
So, that's a very optimistic and
confident view of the world.
All right?
Uh any questions so far?
Okay.
Let's move on to Immanuel Kant. Immanuel
Kant is the greatest philosopher who
ever lived.
We'll be spending a lot of time on
Immanuel Kant throughout the semester,
okay? So, I introduce you to him here.
And he wrote a very influential essay
called What Is Enlightenment?
Why do we have enlightenment? Okay?
All right. So,
enlightenment is man's emergence from a
self-imposed nonage. Nonage is the
inability to use one's own reasoning
without another's guidance. This
knowledge is in self-imposed if its
cause lies not in lack of understanding,
but in indecision and lack of courage to
use one's own mind without another's
guidance. Dare to know, have the courage
to use your own understanding, is
therefore the motto of the
enlightenment. Okay. So,
what he's saying here is that you're
students
and I'm the teacher, okay? I'm
enlightened because I'm using my reason,
but you're not enlightened because
you're not you because you're relying on
my reason.
Right? And what he's saying is that
it's not because you lack the capacity
to reason that's the problem, it's
because you guys are lazy.
Right?
It's just easier for you to just sit sit
there and take notes rather than to
actually read these texts for yourself
and understand them yourself. That's why
you rely on me, okay? But well,
but if you don't ever rely on yourself,
you can never be free to think.
Does that make sense?
That's what he's saying here.
Laziness and cowardice are the reasons
why such a large part of mankind gladly
remain mean minors all their lives long
after nature has freed them from
external eternal external guidance,
okay? You have the capacity
to reason. You can just read these
things by yourself, but you're lazy and
you're cowardly, okay? You don't want
you don't want to make a mistake.
You don't be wrong.
Thus, it is very difficult for the
individual to work himself out of
knowledge which has become almost second
nature to him. He has even grown to like
it and is at first really incapable of
using his own understanding because he
has never been permitted to try it.
Okay?
So,
everyone can do it, but only a few can
do it.
So, what's the solution to this problem?
The solution is
free and open debate.
Does that make sense?
If you're able to access information, if
you're able to access different points
of view, then you're able to to hear the
truth for yourself.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right, so you don't want to find the
truth for yourself,
but if you're able to hear the truth,
hear the opinions of others, then you
can make up for your mind, make up
your own mind as what the truth is. And
you can because you have access to to
reason that God implanted in you, okay?
That's the logic here.
It is more nearly possible, however, for
the public to enlighten itself. Indeed,
if it is only given freedom,
enlightenment is almost inevitable.
There will always be a few independent
thinkers, even among the self-appointed
guardians of the multitude, okay? So,
this is the idea of of reason,
debate, and progress.
If there's a debate, if everyone is able
to hear different opinions,
then society will almost always
progress.
Okay, does that make sense?
This enlightenment requires nothing but
freedom, and the most innocent of all
that may be called freedom, freedom to
make public use of one's reason in all
matters.
Now I hear the cry from all sides, do
not argue. The officer says, do not
argue. Drill, the tax collector, do not
argue, pay. The pastor, do not argue,
believe.
Only one ruler in the world which says,
argue as much as you please, but obey.
We find restrictions on freedom
everywhere, but which restriction is
harmful to enlightenment? Which
restriction is innocent, and which
advances enlightenment? I reply, the
public use of one's reason must be free
at all times, and this alone can bring
enlightenment to mankind. He's arguing
for absolute
freedom of expression.
Okay? Even if it's hate speech.
Even if you say racist things, you're
still allowed to say it because people
have reason and therefore the capacity
to judge for himself or herself what is
true. Whenever you censor something,
you're denying freedom to people.
Okay?
So, this is an absolutist understanding
of freedom.
And this becomes the foundation for, of
course,
um the American constitution of the
American Revolution.
In view of this, he as preacher is not
free and ought not to be free since he's
carrying out the orders of others. On
the other hand, as a scholar who speaks
to his own public through his writings,
the minister in the public use of his
reason enjoys unlimited freedom to use
his own reason and to speak for himself.
Okay, this is a really important idea.
All right. So, I'm your teacher, okay?
I'm a I'm a teacher. Now, I can perceive
myself in different ways.
I can perceive myself as a employee of a
school in China.
Therefore, I must be aware of
uh
censorship laws in China. I must be
aware of what I can teach you and what
and what I cannot teach you. I must also
be aware that my main responsibility is
to make you a citizen of China and
therefore make you feel good about
China, okay? If I see myself as an
employee
of a school in China.
But, if I see myself as a
free individual
in the service of human progress,
then my job is to enlighten you as to
the possibilities
of human reason.
Right? So, I must be honest with you. I
must challenge you to think for
yourself. I must give you the capacity
to
for you to think for yourself, okay?
Therefore, I will not tell you what Kant
says, I will show you what Kant says. So
that you can you can by yourself
interpret what he's saying. Does that
make sense?
Okay, that's the difference. You can
either see yourself as an employee who's
just making money in the service of
others or as a citizen of the world.
As a citizen
dedicated to the progress of human
civilization. Okay? That's your choice.
But just sort of society of ministers
say that church council have the right
to commit itself by oath to a certain
un-ultimate
doctrine in order to secure perpetual
guardianship over all its members and
through them over the people. I say that
this is quite impossible. Such a
contract concluded to keep all further
enlightenment from humanity is simply
null and void even if it should be
confirmed by the sovereign power, by
parliament, and the most solemn
treaties. An epoch cannot conclude a
pact
that will commit succeeding ages,
prevent them from increasing a
significant insights, purging themselves
of errors, and generally progressing in
enlightenment. That would be a crime
against human nature whose proper
destiny lies precisely in such progress.
Okay, this is a radical statement. What
he's saying is that I'm I'm a I'm a of
an older generation than you, right? I
have absolutely no right to tell you
what to think.
I have absolutely no right to tell you
what to think. I can show you
possibilities.
I can argue with you, but I must not
enforce my ideas on you because that
would limit human progress.
Progress
is
determined by a new generation's
capacity to question and negate
uh previous generations' ideas. Okay,
does that make sense?
Right?
All right. So, um this is Voltaire.
Um Voltaire I I don't really want to
spend too much time on, but Voltaire is
considered a celebrity of the
Enlightenment, okay? He was very famous
at that time because he is what we what
we call today a troll, okay? A troll.
Why? Because he's always making fun of
the nobility and the clergy, the powers
that be. And as such, the middle class
basically um worshipped him, okay? They
love his contributions. But he himself
was not a very deep thinker, okay? He
himself was not a great thinker. So, I
don't want to spend too much time on
him.
All right. Um, so let's go move on to
Jean-Jacques Rousseau, who is the most
influential
Enlightenment thinker
in France. It is his It is his ideas
that will drive the French Revolution,
okay?
All right.
So, he wrote a very influential book
called Emile. Emile is his treatise on
education. How should you best educate
children, okay? All right, so let's just
read some basic passages.
If the infant sprang
at one bound from its mother's breast to
the age of reason, the present type of
education would be quite a suitable, but
its natural growth calls for quite a
different training. The mind should be
left undisturbed till its faculties have
developed, for while it is blind, it
cannot see the torch you offer it, nor
can it follow through the vast expanse
of ideas of paths so faintly traced by
reason that the best eyes can scarcely
follow it, okay? So, what he's saying
here is a very controversial
controversial idea. What he's saying
here is that
kindergarten and primary school make no
sense.
Kids come into school to learn math,
to learn language, right?
But the problem is that their faculty
for reason
has not fully developed, okay? It's like
me asking you to
uh fly
even though you don't have wings.
So, what he's saying is this, before the
age of 12, let kids play.
Because if you ask them to come to
school, all that will do is screw up
their minds.
Right? If a child is crawling and you
make the child walk, all that's going to
do is
make the bones
deformed, okay? It's going to really
screw up the legs.
And that's what what Rousseau is saying,
do not ever send kids to learn anything
before the age of 12 because their
faculty of reason has not developed
before the age of 12. And guess what,
guys?
This is the idea of childhood.
Okay? Childhood. Children should have
Should be a lot of play
um until the age of 12. And it comes
from Rousseau.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Therefore, the education of the earliest
years should be merely negative.
Negative just means like
don't have kids
jump in the pool by themselves, okay?
But don't be positive. Don't make them
learn mathematics.
It consists
not in teaching virtue or truth, but in
preserving the heart from vice and from
the spirit of error. If only you could
let the well alone and get others to
follow your example, if you could bring
your scholar to the age of 12 strong and
healthy, but unable to tell his right
hand from his left, the eyes of his
understanding would be open to reason as
soon as you began to teach him.
Free from prejudices and free from
habits, there would be nothing in him to
counteract the effects of your labors.
In your hands, he would soon become the
wisest of men. By doing nothing to begin
with, you would end with a prodigy of
education. Okay? That's the secret of
education. Before age 12, leave the kid
alone. Make sure he's he or she is
healthy.
Make sure he or she is eating well,
but do not teach mathematics, okay?
Because because
by leaving the child alone, you free the
child from bad mental habits.
You allow the child to think for himself
or herself.
Okay? So, the very idea of childhood
comes from Rousseau.
And this is this is an idea that a lot
of
uh middle-class parents will adopt,
okay? I myself
um also believe very heavily in this
idea. I I'm not trying I don't want to
send my kids to school before age 12,
possibly even age 16, okay?
I don't I work in a school, so I don't
really trust schools. I don't trust
teachers. It's it's it's it's it's it's
it's like being a cook and you work in a
restaurant. Like you would you would
never actually go eat in a restaurant,
because you know how how they make the
food, okay?
All right.
Let's continue.
There are two class of men who are
constantly engaged in bodily activity,
peasants and savages, okay? There are
these peasants who work the farm and
these savages who run around in the
forest all day, okay?
So, you think there's no difference, but
in fact, there's a world of difference.
And certainly, neither of these pays the
least attention to the cultivation of
the mind. Peasants are rough, coarse,
and clumsy. Savages are noted not only
for their keen senses, but for great
subtlety of mind.
Savages are really smart. Peasants are
really dull. Why?
Generally speaking, there's nothing
duller than a peasant or sharper than a
savage. What is the cause of this
difference?
The peasant has always done as he was
told, what his father did before him,
what he himself has always done. He's a
creature of habit. He spends his life
almost like an automa an automaton on
the same task. Habitual obedience having
taken the place of reason.
The case of the savage is very
different. He is tied to no one place.
He has no prescribed task, no superior
to obey. He knows no law but his own
will. He is therefore forced to reason
at every step he takes. He can neither
move nor walk without considering the
consequences. Thus, the more his body is
is exercised, the more alert is his
mind. His strength and his reason
increase together and each helps to
explore the other. The savage is an
explorer.
The that savage is a problem-solver.
The savage is free and independent to
make his own destiny. That's the
difference, okay?
So, if you want to educate your child
well, then let the child be a savage and
not a peasant.
Oh, man, seek no further for the author
of evil. Thou art he. There's no evil,
but the evil you do or the evil you
suffer, and both come from yourself.
Evil in general can only spring from
disorder, and in the order of the world,
I find a never-failing system. Evil in
particular cases exists only in the mind
of those who experience it, and this
feeling is not the gift of nature, but
the work of man himself. Pain has no
power over those who have thought
little, look neither before nor after.
Take away our fatal progress, take away
our faults and our vices, take away
man's handiwork, and all is well.
If you take children out of school and
you let and you let them play by
themselves, do what they want,
guess what? They become smart.
They become resilient.
They become educated. They become
curious. They love learning.
So, we, if we try to build structure, if
we try to build civilization, if we move
children away from their state of
nature, we can only screw things up.
Schools are not designed to educate
children. Schools are first and foremost
designed to control children.
Right?
Why? Because we don't like kids running
around.
Okay?
It's that simple.
They're not meant for kids, they're
meant for adults. So that parents don't
have to actually have to see them and
teachers don't have to deal with them.
Okay?
And so that's what Rousseau was saying
and he's he's absolutely right.
All right. Um so that was Emile. Now,
Rousseau also wrote a really famous book
called Discourse on the origin of of
inequality, which will have a major
impact on the French Revolution and the
Enlightenment, okay?
And it's the idea of private property.
Where does private private property come
from?
The first man who, having enclosed a
piece of ground, bethought himself of
saying, "This is mine." and found people
simple enough to believe him, was the
real founder of civil society, okay? So,
we have society because some people want
property, private property.
Okay?
From how many crimes, wars, and murders,
from how many horrors and misfortunes
might not anyone have saved mankind by
pulling up the stakes or filling up the
ditch and just crying to his fellows,
"Beware of listening to this impostor.
You're undone if you if you want to
forget that the fruits of the earth
belong to us all and the earth itself to
nobody." What he's saying is this,
suddenly one day some people in our
society are like, "Oh, this is mine.
This ground is mine. You can't come
here."
We should have all been like,
"What are you talking about? That makes
no sense.
How can you claim this ground for
yourself?"
Well, we didn't do that. In fact, we
claimed our own ground or we let we we
just let let let have their own crowd
ground and because of this because of
the idea of because of the idea of
private property, we now have
inequality,
patriarchy,
war.
Okay?
This is where war and patriarchy and
inequality come from because of some
people's insistent on having private
property.
All right.
Okay.
Any questions so far?
Is all clear to you? All right. So,
let's move on to the final book.
The social contract. Okay? The social
contract is the Bible of the French
Revolution. It is the
book that is most influent in the most
influential development of the thinkers
of the French Revolution. All right. The
most famous sentence
um that the sentence that begins of
social contract is
"Man is born free and everywhere he is
in chains. Here's one who thinks he is
the master of others, yet he's more
enslaved than they are." Okay?
So, we were born free, but we choose to
become slaves.
But not only that, the people who have
enslaved us think they are masters, but
in fact, they're more enslaved than us
because they are trapped by the system.
You understand? Slavery is a system that
enslaves all.
It's slavery It's a system where a few
oppress the others. Slavery system where
an idea has oppressed everyone,
especially the masters.
All right?
We see at once that on this account of
things, certain questions can be laid
aside. Whose business it it is to make
laws. They are acts of the general will.
Is the principle of the law? No, because
he is a member of the state. Can a law
be unjust? No, because nothing is unjust
towards itself. How can we be both free
and subject to laws? There's no problem
about this because the laws are nothing
but records of our violations. Okay.
So, this is a really important idea
um that I need to explain to you, all
right? And it it becomes a basis for a
new type of society uh promoted by the
French Revolution.
All right. So,
um
Rousseau is trying to reason from
general principles as to how to form a
good society, okay? A social contract
where everyone chooses to participate in
a society and is not compelled to
participate in the society.
And he says this, this:
There are two types of will. There's a
general will and there's the particular
will.
Okay? General will is what we can agree
on if we are left to reason by
ourselves.
Particular will is what we believe if we
are part of a group of people.
Okay? A part of a interest. So, let's
let's just say for example,
Bei- like central government in China is
like, "I want to spend $10 billion on
roads, on new roads."
Where should we invest this money? Okay?
General will is everyone agrees that we
should invest these roads where they're
most needed in China, right? Maybe
Guizhou, maybe Yunnan, the poorest
parts, because it would do the most
good. We can all agree on that, right?
But, because we are in Beijing,
we will be like, "No, you should put the
money in Beijing." That's a particular
will.
Okay? So, in other words, society, if it
is to function well, must be based
entirely on the general will and negate
the particular will, on the common
interest. And that's why everything
works, because
if laws are based on the general will,
then all the laws are acceptable to
people because they are the laws are
just an expression of the general will.
And the king, he's just acting out the
general will. So, the king is acceptable
to everyone, okay? Does that make sense?
The problem with this, of course, is
that that's not how the world works,
okay?
There's actually no one in the world who
is like, "Oh, I should do this because
of the general will."
It's always a particular will, right?
Does that make sense? And so, this is
the
major
um divergence between the French
Revolution and American Revolutions. The
French Revolution, it is fundamentally
idealistic. It believes that people are
capable of
considering the common interest.
The American Revolution denies this,
okay? So, we will discuss American
Revolution later on, but I I just want
you to be aware of this, okay? The
French Revolution, it's based on the
idea of the general will, that everyone
is capable of reason and of promoting
the the common interest. The American
Revolution
refuses to believe this, okay?
All right.
Each of us puts his person and all and
all his power in common under supreme
direction of the general will, and in
our corporate capacity, we receive each
member as an indivisible part of the
whole, okay? So, as long as we are
capable of reason, which we are, we can
understand the general will.
If the populace
held its celebrations
on the base of adequate information
about the citizens communicating with
one another, what emerged from all that
particular wills should would always be
the general will, and the decision would
always be good, okay? So, if you only
think about the common interest,
everyone would come to the same
conclusion about everything, okay?
If the general will is to emerge
clearly, it's important that there
should be no partial society within the
state, and that each citizen should
think only his own thoughts, which was
indeed
I'm continually astonished that such a
simple sign of good government isn't
recognized, or perhaps men do recognize
it, but aren't honest honest enough to
say so. What's the purpose of any
particular association? The preservation
and prosperity of its members. And what
is the surest sign of their preservation
and prosperity? Their number and the
population growth.
That's the sign you're looking for.
Other things being equal, the
unquestionably best government is the
one under which the population increases
most without external help from
naturalizing foreigners or establishing
colonies. The government under which the
population shrinks is the worst. Over to
you, calculators. Count, measure,
compare. Okay. This is a really
important idea here.
What Rousseau is saying is that not only
can we
deduce good government from general
principles,
but good government can be measured.
Okay?
So, we can know how we are doing as a
society through measurement. By
measuring things. By By counting things.
Okay?
Count, measure, compare. And that's what
progress means. Now, what we'll know
what we'll learn later on is this is
actually a really dumb idea, okay? But
for now, I want you to be aware of this.
And the French Revolution will embrace
this.
And that's why um in the French
Revolution they will introduce the
metric system.
Okay? The metric system comes from the
French Revolution. And the French And
the metric system is now used by every
country in the world except two, right?
There are the two countries in the world
who don't use the metric system. They
are
Do you guys know?
There are There are exactly two
countries in the world that do not use
the metric system.
They are
Can you guess?
These two These two countries are the
countries that are most
that were most against the French
Revolution. These countries are
America and Britain.
Okay?
Yeah, it's true. In China we use
Celsius, right?
When you go to America, they don't use
Celsius.
They use Fahrenheit.
Okay?
And when you go to Britain, they use
something called the imperial system.
So so so so so just be aware when when
you go to America, you will hear terms
like oh
uh 12 yards and you're like what is 12
yards, okay?
So so so they don't actually use the
metric system in America.
But but everyone else does.
But I'm wrong to speak of a Christian
republic, those two terms are mutually
exclusive. Christianity preaches only
servitude and dependence, its spirit is
so favorable to tyranny that it always
profits by such a regime. Genuine
Christians are made to be slaves and
they know it and don't mind much. This
short life counts for too little in
their eyes. Okay? So Rousseau is
rejecting religion in government.
This is the idea of separation of church
and state
which becomes the basis for the French
nation-state. It's very important idea
and during the French Revolution, this
will lead to civil wars
between the peasants who want to be
Christians
and the revolutionaries who want to
establish a secular state.
The dogmas of civil religion ought to be
few, simple, and exactly worded with no
explanation or commentary. Its positive
dogmas are the existence of a mighty,
intelligent, and beneficent divinity
possessed of foresight and providence,
the life to come, the happiness of the
just, the punishment of the wicked, the
sanctity of the social contract, and the
laws, and just one dogma of exclusion,
and exclusion of intolerance which is a
feature of the cult we have rejected,
okay? So what Rousseau is saying here is
that the new society should now have a
new religion, a state religion that is
based on reason.
Okay? And this new religion of reason
must reject all other religions because
these religions are intolerant of each
other.
And that's why in France today
there's so much conflict between
uh there's so much conflict in in
society, okay? You you have a lot of
Islamic immigrants and they're always in
conflict with the French state because
the French state insists
on secular um
on a secular religion, but they
Islamists want to practice their own
religion, okay?
Okay, so that's it, okay? So these ideas
that we looked at
will now become the basis of the French
Revolution.
All right? So next class we will look at
the French Revolution.
All right, so I so I I know this was a
lot, but are there any questions about
what we've learned so far?
Why peasants are so loyal to the
religion?
Excuse me?
Why peasant will be so loyal to the
religion?
Why are peasants so loyal to the
religion, right?
Yes.
Okay, great. Great great question. All
right. Sorry, let me um
All right.
So what you learn in this class is that
the Christian religion
it is
something that is um adopted, okay? Or
enforced.
But over generations, right? Over the
centuries, it becomes part of your
tradition.
All right? So what is religion?
Okay?
Okay, people.
Okay, what do we know that people are
loyal to? People are loyal to their
home, right? Their land.
And that's true, right? People like
being in a place.
They they don't want to move. Most
people in the world don't want to move.
If you give people the choice of like of
Chinese the choice of like just moving
to America, you think everyone would go,
but no, no, no. Most people would not go
because they want to live
where they grew up, okay? So they're
loyal to the land, they're loyal to the
family,
they're loyal to
um tradition,
or culture.
They're loyal to food.
Okay?
Right? This is true for most people.
If you grew up eating, I don't know,
rice,
you don't want to eat potatoes. You want
to eat rice.
Okay?
So, what this tells us is that
people are first and foremost
people of habit.
Does that make sense?
Why? Why people of habit? Because this
is a really important idea, okay? Um and
I know this is a strange idea but
because it
feels good.
Do you understand?
Because when you do something out of
habit, you feel good about yourself.
When you break this habit, you feel bad
about yourself.
And the way that you the only way that
you know if something is good or bad is
how you feel about it, okay?
Right?
Like you're eating rice and you're happy
eating rice because you've been doing
this all your life.
But then and now you you're eating
potatoes and like it kind of tastes
weird. But I tell you, "Hey, no, no.
Eating potatoes is better for you.
It's how it's more more nutritious, it's
cheaper." You don't care, okay? It's all
about feeling good.
So, you resort to habit and habit is in
the land, the family, the tradition, and
the food.
Does that make sense?
And guess what?
These ideas are all encapsulated in
religion. Because religion is what
determines
your culture, your food. It's what your
family practices. It is your connection
to your family, it's connection to your
land.
Okay? And that's why people will die for
the religion because the religion is
really a metaphor or encapsulation of
all these things that people understand
and know and love.
Does that make sense?
Okay? Now, what you will learn in this
class is people don't just don't die for
religion. They also die for ideas, which
include
the nation.
Right? The nation-state. Because all
that because because what you will learn
in this class is what the French
Revolution will do is sort of a process
where religion
becomes part of the nation.
Our ideas of religion become
transplanted into the nation.
Okay? So, people will also die for the
nation. That's why you have these
incredibly
devastating wars like World War I and
World War II, where people will die for
the nation.
Okay? And they won't even think about
it.
But it starts in the It starts in the
French Revolution. Okay? Does that make
sense to you? Okay, great.
Yeah, like
on the mission that it was based on
the fact that
the new society and new government is
based on
reason.
So, how can a religion be based on
reason?
Okay.
All right.
Good question. So, how can a religion be
based on reason? All right.
So,
traditionally, religion
is given us to by God, okay? Right?
Every religion is like, "Well, we have
this religion because
God told us to believe in him." Okay?
So, So, and the way you do that is
through priests,
who then tell you what to believe.
Okay? So, this is the way that most
religion is practiced, right?
What the Enlightenment thinkers are
saying, especially Rousseau, is "No, no,
no, no, this system doesn't really work,
right? Because
you have reason.
And therefore, you have the capacity to
access God.
So, you don't really need priest, right?
So, we can just
think reasonably
what religion should be like.
And from first principles, you can
deduce
the religion.
Right?
Right? Does that make sense? Now, if you
use reason from first first principles
about what religion should be like,
what are they? Well, first of all,
there is a God, okay? First of all,
there is a God. Second of all is that
there is heaven and hell. If you do good
things, you go to heaven. If you do bad
things, you go to hell. Right? That's
the second thing. Third thing is
good people go to heaven. Therefore, you
should do good.
Okay?
And then fourth would be like
if you believe in these things, you are
free to believe anything else.
For example, you're like
I don't know. I
I believe that animals have the same
rights as humans.
Well, that doesn't contradict what we
already believe.
Therefore, you can believe that animals
can go to heaven as well.
Did you understand?
So, what Rousseau is saying is that for
just from general principles
just because just if you're able to
exercise reason by yourself, you should
you should be able to
deduce the basic principles of an
organized state religion.
And that's what he does in the in the
social contract.
It becomes a basis again for the French
Revolution.
Okay? Does that Does that make sense?
All right.
Any more questions?
Okay.
Um great. Okay. So, I apologize for um
the length of this class, but but the
French Revolution is really complicated,
and I really need to explain some basic
ideas to you, okay? So, next class we
will do Robespierre.
Right?